[Music]
[Music]
Tuesday night night owl sound played an
unreleased Drake and future song on
Instagram live and people took note of
the offensive lyrics toward Kylie and
Kendall Jenner and Gigi Hadid yeah of
course there were rumors that Drake in
Kylie dated last year and Drake his
friends with Kendall as well so here's
the lyric so future rats yeah I'm a
hater - society real beep Kylie Jenner
that's a side piece yeah I got 20 mother
eopns
Kylie's and then Drake says yeah I got
20 damn Kendall's young slim bodies and
they in vogue yeah I got 20 F and Gigi's
wow that's that's tough man all right so
here's the lyric so future also you yeah
so you talked about the lyrics so Drake
took to Instagram to put on the context
into it a song that Mark ran last night
on night Allison live set shouldn't have
been played it's a song that leaked
three years ago and got scrapped shortly
after he was just going too deep into
the Drake future catalog last thing I
want to do is wake up having any friends
of mine feeling disrespected so I just
had to say that to start off the day
that's interesting though to be able to
even have words out like that and even
if it's been leaked the fact that he
even wrote those kind of lyrics right
because as a song because they leaked in
2018 yeah like Drake says the song is
about three years old and I can't member
exactly I think he met the Kardashians
before then so he wouldn't friends with
them but my thing is like even
regardless if he knew those people those
lyrics are really degrading towards
women because what Drake says it is
message this morning is oh I don't want
my friends to think I was disrespect
like he's really apologizing Oh actually
know them now like that's why I regret
those lyrics he doesn't say you know
what do you be saying the same thing if
we you know people he didn't know or it
was just about women
he's the Basie saying I have 20 side
pieces that's basically what they're
saying I have 20 women but I can I can
call up so yeah like a certain point
it's not about Kylie and Kendall Jenner
and the fact that you know them it's
about the fact that you're saying this
about women in 2020 like I know whatever
hip-hop music has a certain style of it
sometimes but yeah overall message is
really degrading towards women it really
is and I and again that you made a
really good point because rap music
still has the tendency to do that where
it's degrading women it's it's moving
slowly it's getting cleaner but it's
still there if you really listen to some
of the rap music and we forget Drake is
really a rap singer like he is the one
who brings the core of his music is rap
and once we get these little songs where
it's kind of poppy and people kind of
fall onto his you know those those those
Tootsie Roll challenges and all that we
forget that he actually does love doing
rap so it's just the fact that he was
able to put words out like that where it
is about his friends and he's talking
about Kylie and I think that's why he
was so apologetic was because it's
famous people but I wonder what the
response is going to be from Kylie and
Gigi once they hear the lyrics right
yeah pollicis Drake doesn't seem very
happy these days I'm glad I don't have
friends like that
yeah like once again I don't even think
it matters that he's friends with them I
think regardless if you're saying like
anything about women in that kind of
regard in 2020 he just seems really
unnecessary so we wouldn't be talking
about it unless it was about Kylie and
about Gigi so it's getting more ignore
because it's his friends right so I mean
we think that's degrading about women
and we we don't really bring it up it's
because of his friends and it's also too
like Drake doesn't often make public
statements like this so it's part of
that that you responded so quickly like
it was lilly within 24 hours you made
this poster boaters who you obviously
wanted to get something out there but
yeah I do think there's still a weird
thing that yeah like to say anything
like that about women but anyways